he walked does this guy walk everywhere
he only walks is that why he has the
cane that must be it
hi my name is John and I'm a private
investigator my name is Elizabeth and
I'm a private investigator my name is
Andy I'm a private investigator
I've been doing it for about 28 years
I've been a private detective for about
two-and-a-half years you have to have
some poise under pressure and some
confidence I've been a private
investigator for about eight years it
teaches you how to manage stress a lot
you can't lose your cool the skills for
the job or observation being able to
read people today I've been tasked with
a very important project finding Waldo
I'm not feeling so confident about
finding Waldo today I've never opened
one of these books before so I have no
strategy I should be able to nail this I
don't know much about this guy Waldo so
I don't know what's gonna happen today
okay here we go all right so we got a
ski resort here and also there's a
postcard here now I didn't know Waldo
was gonna be leaving any sort of clue
behind I got that is it Wow I feel
really confident now
this is confusing I can't look there
because that's all Waldo and I keep
thinking I found Waldo over there
introducing it
so he's yodeling he walked across walked
across the ski slopes today which is
interesting most people ski across the
ski slope one must wonder is he's
sending this postcard to throw us off
the trail if I had these sorts of clues
going out there in the field for real I
would I would take that into
consideration how long did it take the
other investigator did he already get it
I've got her here boom there's a big
pile oh I found him boom I got him I got
him come on he's right there he's
walking over here right there right yep
what did the investigator get the other
one really yes okay bragging rights
I feel great are you or do you feel good
about my time I nailed that one so I'm
feeling better and got more confidence
but we'll try this and see if it wasn't
just luck Eddie oh no I shouldn't have
picked this one this has way too many
here got it boom
so Waldo says he loves train stations
okay so if I was maybe on a surveillance
assignment looking for this guy I would
maybe focus on train stations if I
didn't know where he was gonna be on a
given day got him
I'm losing it I feel like I'm slipping
it's getting tougher tell me that's not
him we know what this guy wears there's
the cows there's the cows going crazy I
got him I got him I found him who'd ever
beat that
who's beat that seriously no seriously
so do I get a prize I'm pleased with my
performance I mean I expected it would
be more challenging if I sat here for
you know 10 or 12 minutes and couldn't
find Waldo I probably wouldn't have a
job once this video gets released I
think this does say something about
being a good PI because you have to like
focus on exactly what you're looking for
and cut out everything else my skills
definitely came in handy I know how to
focus
I don't think detectives are better than
the normal person now that I've seen it
I'm gonna have to probably go get a copy
[Music]